[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal sur TVfil 78 voici les
principaux titres de cette édition du 5
mai 2015 2000 personnes ont marché pour
Moussa hier à trappe cette adolescent de
14 ans victime d'une fusillade qui a
éclaté au squir Albert Camu moment
d'émotion mais aussi de collè et
d'incompréhension au Parti socialiste la
primaire pour désigner le candidat à
l'élection régionale en Île-de-France se
déroulera le 28 mai la légitimité de
jean-pauluchon le président sortant est
contesté dans son propre camp il s'est
déplacé en tout cas dans un lycée de
trappe lundi pour faire un point sur les
investissements dans les établissements
du secondaire et puis politique toujours
et toujours au Parti socialiste quatre
motions vont s'affronter en juin lors du
congrès de Poitier quatre motions pour
définir les orientation et mettre fin au
querel invité du journal Amr jeard élu
PS de véisie représentant de la motion
la fabrique vous l'avez suivi hier dans
notre journal sur notre antenne en
direct 2000 personnes réunies malgré la
pluie dans les rues de trappe en début
de soirée pour rendre hommage à Moussa
de l'émotion de la dignité le récit de
Catherine zulato et de William
l des roses blanches à la main malgré la
pluie un long cortège 2000 personnes
dans les rues de trape jusqu'au squir
Camu où Moussa 14 ans est tombé sous les
balles le 1er mai dernier un cortège
encadré par des membres du service
jeunesse en gilets jaunes des banderoles
qui réclamament une paix sociale dignité
et émotion le départ a été donné de la
place des Merisiers devant la famille
les amis les proches à leur côté des
politiques de gauche comme de droite pas
de discours pas de mot juste une envie
de comprendre pour que cela cesse
vivement qu'on trouve qui a tué ce gosse
on trouvera parce que c'est pas possible
de laisser dans l'irresponsabilité
l'assassinat d'un gamin de 14 ans c'est
pas possible qui qui était un un gamin
adorable quoi vraiment moi quand j'ai
appris quand j'ai appris sa mort je le
dis
tranquillement malgré mon âge mon
expérience j'ai pleuré parce que
c'était un petit bonhomme come on
devrait en avoir tous comme enfant dans
la vie dans la foule certains
collectaient des fonds au profit de la
famille pour les aider à financer les
funérailles au Mali j'ai fait le tour de
voir tout le monde que tout le monde
participe mett une pièce là quand même
on a eu des personnes qui ont été
généreuses qui ont mis des billet de 50
€ 20 € donc c'est une bonne chose et moi
aussi j'appelle de tous mes vœux pour
que ce qu'on vient de vivre là que ça ne
recommence plus et que cette marche
serve à quelque chose le long cortège a
terminé sa marche squir Camu douleur
d'une famille dépôts de fleurs et un
message pour le petit soldat Moussa
parti au Paradis recueillement demandé
pour tous si les si les journalistes
veulent respecter la souffrance de la
famille et fermer leur leurs écrans il
nous rendont à
c'est une belle initiative parce que on
VO aujourd'hui tous les
thraapistes n a pas des communautaires
par que tous les trap qui sont à VI à TR
aujourd'hui ils sont là la solenité et
les questionnements aussi l'enfant du
quartier ne doit pas être mort pour rien
disent certains qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour changer ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour les jeunes les habitants de de Camu
pas de travail pas d'emploi j'ai
vraiment à H clos donc j'espère que que
l'électrochoc aura lieu finalement
électrochoc et que ça changera et que ça
bougera tu peux mettre la police tu peux
mettre des hélicoptères tu peux mettre
tout ce que tu veux ça ça n'arrangera
pas le vivre ensemble commee un quartier
à l'autre on se respecte et on se dit
bonjour en traversant la rue voilà il
faut faire des choses ensemble et ça ça
se fe par le sport par la culture je
crois encore à ça la mort de Moussa
reste encore inexpliquée conflit entre
quartiers ou guerre de territoire sur
fond de trafic de stupéfiant attrappe
ilire Camu et ailleurs dans la commune
il y aura un avant et un après
Moussa
aucun débordement à l'issue de cette
marche silencieuse des agents du service
jeunesse de la ville en gilet jaune
encadr la foule la police municipale
était également aux avant-postes ainsi
que des policiers nationaux en tenue
mais également en civil et parmi les
policiers présents le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique à
qui nous avons demandé de faire le point
sur la sécurité justement dans cette
commune trappe est une ville avec une
délinquence tout à fait classique et
avec des points de préoccupation qui
sont bien bel et bien les trafic de
stupéfiants et là on ne peut pas exclure
que il y ait eu que que Moussa soit une
victime
collatérale malheureuse bien évidemment
d'une guerre de territoire pour le
trafic de stupéfiant depuis longtemps
c'est la première fois qu'un meurtre de
cette façon là est commis de sous cette
formel a lieu dans les ivelines c'est un
mode opératoire de vrai voyou qui passe
complètement toutes les bornes je crois
qu'il ne faut pas confondre euh ce que
l'on peut ressentir et évoquer en
période de stress et en période
d'émotion et la situation réel et au
quotidien moi je peux vous dire que
l'année passée les services de police de
la sécurité publique que je dirige ont
doublé le nombre d'affaires réussies en
matière de trafic de stup et on doublé
le nombre de personnes interpellé pour
trafic de stupéfiant donc c'est un signe
également de présence et d'action de la
police nous restons à traape où lundi
matin le président socialiste de la
région était en déplacement un
déplacement au lycée de la plaine de
naufle pour annoncer des moyens
supplémentaire mais aussi pour occuper
le terrain alors que sa candidature pour
un nouveau mandat en décembre ne fait
pas l'unanimité dans son propre camp
Mélan poquet William
l centre de documentation cours
d'informatique et représentation de
théâtre trois thématiqu pour une visite
permettant d'évaluer les avancées des
rénovations mais aussi les besoins de
l'établissement trapiste
près de 500 élèves étudient et
particularité un tiers d'entre eu su une
spécialité artistique cinéma théâtre ou
plastique on fait un travail
considérable on a engagé ce qu'on
appelle un plan provisionnel
d'investissement pour 10 ans et qui va
concerner des dizaines de de lycées avec
des moyens très importants parce
qu'aujourd'hui on construit
difficilement un lycée à moins de 20 ou
30 millions d'euros mis en place en 2012
ce plan prévisionnel d'investissement
court jusqu'en 2022 le lycée de la
plaine de nafle fait actuellement partie
des établissements prioritaires dans le
cadre des rénovations ce lycée a obtenu
de 140000 € pour améliorer l'étanchéité
des fenêtres et 45000 € pour
l'installation de la vidéo surveillance
extérieure nous connaissons ce
lycée on a un programme de rénovation
qu'il faut accélérer la rénovation
complète 2016 et auparavant il y a des
travaux à opérer
on a vu notamment la cantine le C et
cetera et ça ça peut se réaliser je
pense dans le cadre de nos décisions qui
vont intervenir en 2015 donc on est venu
pour donner un coup d'accélérateur parce
que ce lycée est un lycée qui a de très
bons
résultats malgré un état qui n'est pas
parfait et avec des équipes pédagogiques
vraiment remarquabl des études sont
actuellement en cours le budget de la
région pour les lycées pour l'année 2015
s'élève à 74 million d'euros c'est le
deè budget de la région l'île-de-fance
gère 471 établissements secondaires 250
d'entre eux ont été rénovés 60 à 80
chantiers sont actuellement en cours une
visite remarquée à 7 mois des élections
régionale Jean-Paul hchon se présente à
la candidature du PS pour briguer un 4e
mandat nous allons parler politique
toujours et toujours du Parti socialiste
le Congrès national se déroulera les 6
et 7 juin prochain un Poitier plusieurs
motions quatre seront présenté les
militants vont devoir faire leur choix
pour l'orientation qui leur semble la
plus appropriée amrose adjard bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes élu d'opposition au
PSA avéisi vous défendez la motion des
dans les ivelines baptisé La Fabrique on
va y venir juste peut-être votre regard
sur la situation dans laquelle se trouve
Jean-Paul Huchon qu' qu'on a vu dans le
reportage juste auparavant l'actuel
président de région qui souhaite
prolonger après 17 ans à la tête de
l'île- de France sa première adjointe se
présente aussi dans une primaire le nom
de Benoît amamont est évoqué également
la situation est plutôt délicate le
Parti socialiste se déchire vous n'avez
pas forcément apprécier ce que vous
voyez en ce moment non je crois pas
qu'il se qu'il se déchire réellement
mais effectivement c'est vrai que
Jean-Paul lchon est dans une situation
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas évidente il
faut quand même saluer le bilan de la
gauche qui a été réalisé pendant
maintenant depuis 98 depuis plusieurs
années par jean-pa Luchon et par la
gauche au niveau de la région
île-de-fance maintenant qu'il y a un
débat au sein du Parti socialiste et la
primaire viendra justement euh dire qui
sera finalement la tête de liste au
régional pour pour mais les propos sont
dures tout de même jean-pauluchon qui
dit que sa première vice-présidente tout
de même n'a pas d'idée par exemple alors
je pense pas qu'il faut aller dans ce
dans ce type de de débat là on n'est pas
là je pense pas je suis que je suis
fondé à venir commenter les les en tant
qu'adhérant socialiste aussi quel regard
vous portez là-dessus parce que votre
motion on va y venir rapidement mais
votre motion justement se se bat contre
cette idée de bloc contre bloc vous êtes
plutôt une une voie alternative de pour
tempérer un petit peu les choses donc là
ce genre de situation là de tension
c'est pas forcément ce qui peut servir
au Parti socialiste en ce moment mais
effectivement je pense que dans tous les
cas il faut aller au-delà d'une question
de débat et de question d'ego entre
entre plusieurs personnes he que ce soit
Jean-Paul echon Marie-Pierre de la
Gonterie ou bien ou bien ben amont s'il
rentre s'il rentre en scène
effectivement c'est une question de
proposition et de et de et de projet
pour la région - de-fance pour les
prochaines années c'est sur ça que les
militants devront se se fonder pour
faire leur choix toujours autour du
Parti socialiste il a eu un sondage ce
matin un sondage réalisé par l'institut
odoxa publié dans donc ce matin le
Premier ministre est plblicité par 70 %
des Français pour représenter le Parti
socialiste à l'élection présidentielle
de 2017 François Hollande lui n'est
souhaité que par 24 % de la population
manuel Vals c'est l'avenir du Parti
socialiste il y a un avenir au Parti
socialiste peu importe par qui il est
incarné que ce soit manuel Vals François
Hollande ou d'autres d'autres personnes
sachant que quel que soit le candidat au
second tour il serait battu par Marine
Le Pen Nicolas Sarkozi qui eux seraiit
au second tour aujourd'hui il y a
urgence en tout cas au Parti socialiste
vous savez les sondages plusieurs mois
ou plusieurs années avant avant
l'échéance ne veulent pas forcément dire
grand chose donc don é pour Parti
socialiste dernière départementale le
département desvelin aujourd'hui est
détenu uniquement par la droite on peut
pas le nier effectivement il y a une
situation qui est préoccupante au niveau
du du Parti socialiste mais c'est une
situation qui est aussi préoccupante au
niveau français aujourd'hui le Parti
socialiste c'estit dans quelle voie se
diriger bien c'est l'objet justement
l'objet du Congrès c'est là où on a
vraiment un vrai débat démocratique qui
se fait au sein de notre parti parfois
cela ne donne pas assez de lisibilité au
français puisqu'ils pensent que nous
nous écharpons alors que c'est vraiment
un lieu démocratique expression donc
effectivement ça me permet de parler
justement de cette de cette motion mais
je pense que nous allons y arriver
bientôt donc oui effectivement il va
savoir où il va aller par ces débats là
notamment à la à la suite des à la suite
du du congrès de Poitier qui aura lieu
en juin mais c'est tout de même
surprenant on peut imaginer qu'un
président au milieu de son mandat a tout
même un cap défini avec un parti qui qui
le soutient or c'est pas du tout le cas
aujourd'hui encore on au Parti
socialiste on est en train d'espérer
quelle que soit la tendance quelle que
soit la motion qui sera défendue au au
congrès de Poitier qu'il y aura des des
inflexions dans un sens ou dans un autre
le cap n'est pas clair aujourd'hui le
cap le cap qui est défendu par François
Hollande est celui qu'il qu'il a annoncé
depuis depuis depuis son élection hein
je veux dire il y a pas de surprise
visà-is de C par l'ensemble'est pas
effectivement souhaité par l'ensemble
des socialistes c'est un c'est un c'est
un fait on peut pas on peut pas le nier
encore une fois maintenant effectivement
il faut faire confiance aussi à la
politique gouvernementale il y a le
moment du Congrès pour justement
débattre et justement après par la suite
avoir des inflexions si elles sont
nécessaires au niveau de la politique
menée par par la majorité faire de la
politique de la base vers le haut c'est
le mot d'ordre de votre motion tout à
fait c'est-à-dire faudit mieux écouter
les militants la population il faut sont
pas écoutés il faut l'écouter il faut
revenir justement à un lien entre d'une
part la population que ce soit les
militants socialistes mais pas seulement
d'une part tous les Français et
effectivement avec avec le haut qui doit
prendre en considération un certain
nombre de remarques qui ont été faites
puisque on le sait aujourd'hui dans un
pour restaurer la confiance entre les
Français et le politique il y a deux
moyens de faire l'attitude d'une part
mais aussi les résultats l'attitude
c'est ce sur quoi nous proposons un
certain nom de choses également sur
comment arriver aux résultats qui ont
été qui ont été promis et c'est c'est
par cela qu' qu'on arrivera à restaurit
la confiance entre les Français d'une
part et la et le Parti socialiste
d'autre part aujourd'hui la motion que
vous défendez est en nette opposition
avec la politique qui est menée par le
gouvernement absolument pas nous sommes
ni en opposition par rapport au
gouvernement ni en opposition par
rapport par rapport au fondeur il y a
des bonnes idées qui sont partout
effectivement comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure il y a une nécessité de
restaurer la confiance restaurer la
confiance par l'attitude qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est la question de l' éthique et
de l'exemplarité que notre motion défend
malheureusement ces deux notions sont
trop absentes du monde politique depuis
de très très nombreuses années ce qui
fait le lit finalement de l'extrême
droite qui entre guillemets surf sur la
vague du tous pourri et bien nous avons
des des propositions très concrètes
vis-à-vis de cela notamment sur la
question de l'inéligibilité à vie des
politiques qui auraient été condamnés
pour des faits de corruption ou d'abut
de biens sociaux mais également la
question du non cumulle des mandat dans
le temps donc pas uniquement de fonction
mais également dans le temps pour
justement donner l'impression mais pas
que l'impression de faire voir que c'est
une réalité qu'il y a vraiment de
l'oxygénation de la vie politique et que
les que les caristes en politiqu n'ont
plus leur place aujourd'hui en France et
là ça s'adresse directement à jeanpon
par exemple on est qu mandats qui qui
souhaite Briger un nouveau mandat je
pense qu'il faut savoir parfois tirer
les conséquences d'un certain nombre de
mandats qui ont été faits il faut savoir
tirer les conséquences d'un bilan qui a
été réalisé des bilan des points
positifs mais aussi négatifs mais aussi
savoir à un moment certainement préparer
une succession 86 propositions variées
que vous proposez dans cette motion une
réforme fiscale la fusion de l'impôt sur
le revenu CSG de la prime pour l'emploi
également moratoire sur la baisse des
dotations aux collectivités locales
déménagement du siège du PS aussi en
blieue parisienne il faut se rapprocher
aussi c'est s'écartter de Paris du
microcosme parisien tout à fait vous
savez les mesures on a on nous dit
souvent que c'est une mesure qui est
iconoclaste ou un peu ou un peu
symbolique ou uniquement symbolique mais
j'ai envie de dire euh la société est
faite de symboles et les symboles sont
importants puisqu'ils envoient des
signaux à la population effectivement je
pense que un des moyens ce n'est pas la
Pan ce n'est pas une solution qui sera
qui changera ou qui révolutionnera le
monde en revanche effectivement le fait
de donner des gages de confiance auprès
de la population française montrer que
nous sommes proches du peuple c'est un
signe intéressant et je pense que nous
avons tout intérêt à délocaliser notre
siège non plus du coup à Paris mais en
banlieu sur ces sur ces propositions que
que vous faites là vous parliez du
symbole du déplacement du du siège du
Parti socialiste et sur la question des
finances maintenant sur cette question
du moratoire sur la baisse des dotations
au collectivités on le sait bien l'État
doit faire des économies de toute façon
donc là est-ce que c'est pas démagogique
que de proposer de suspendre tout
simplement les les baisses de dotation
alors il faut savoir pérécouer cet
effort-l effectivement il y a des il y a
des villes qui n'ont pas euh qui ne sont
pas beaucoup impactés finalement par
cette par cette baisse de la dotation
globale de financement je pense à ma
ville à à véis ville coublet qui a la
chance d'être une ville extrêmement
riche 86 millions d'euros de de budget
c'est la ville la plus riche du du
département c'est effectivement la ville
la la la plus riche du département avec
seulement 21000 habitants alors tant
mieux tant mieux pour pour pour visi en
revanche effectivement l'effort qui sera
demandé euh à véisy n'est pas le même
que celui pour saint-arnaou en Yveline
qui est une commune rurale qui a besoin
justement de ces dotations globales de
financement pour pouvoir maintenir les
services publics il est important de
savoir pérécer l'effort et de savoir
mesurer l'effort en fonction de ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin donc ceux qui ont
plus besoin effectivement il faut
arrêter cette baisse de la dotation
globale des financements enfin ceux qui
l'ont ceux qui ont besoin de cet argent
là ceux qui n ont pas besoin
effectivement je pense qu'on peut leur
demander un effort supplémentaire quel
poids et quel espoir vous vous pouvez
avoir dans le dans dans le cadre de
cette de ce ce vote pour cette motion au
mois de juin on le sait il y a deux
motions qui se dégagent c'est celle des
frondeurs et puis celle portée par la
voix principal hein du Parti socialiste
on va dire vous avez la marge encore
pour manœuvrer un peu ne serait-ce que
dans le département par exemple
département de benoî mon d'ailleurs qui
propose l'une des motions celle des
frondeurs vous savez finalement la la
position qui est très claire qui est la
nôre celle de qui refuse le bloc contre
bloc est une position qui intéresse
beaucoup beaucoup de militants
socialistes puisque on donne en
spectacle finalement depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant une sorte de V ville
politique dont les Français ne veulent
pas dont les militants socialistes ne
veulent pas et puis nous permettons
justement de donner un peu une autre
respiration et nous abordons des thèmes
qui ne sont pas abordés par les par les
deux autres motions voir les trois
autres motions notamment la question de
l'éthique et de l'exemplarité comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est une
question qui fche un peu trop je pense
dans les autres motions parce que il y a
sans doute des précarrés à à défendre
nous n'avons pas peur d'aller là-dessus
et c'est effectivement des points qui
séduisent beaucoup de militants et je
suis très confiant pour la suite
l'objectif c'est de faire suffisant de
voix pour ensuite pouvoir peser au sein
du Parti socialiste l'objectif ce n'est
pas une question de personne c'est une
question d'idée donc notre objectif sera
réussi du moment où les principales
idées que nous que nous portons pourront
effectivement prospérer au sein du Parti
socialiste mais surtout au niveau
français et l'Union pour conclure
l'union sera possible ensuite une fois
que la primaire sera passé une fois que
la primaire pardon une fois que le
Congrès sera passé ceci dit ça vaut
aussi pour les différentes primaires
mais une fois que le Congrès sera passé
l'union sera possible tout le monde va
rentrer dans le rang et bien c'est notre
souhait le plus cher efftivement il faut
que nous soyons unis il faut que nous
donnions vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'un CAP il faut que ce cap soit très
lisible puisque il y a un cap maintenant
il faut qu'il soit lisible à nous d'être
suffisamment fort pour avoir cette union
pour ne pas donner en spectacle encore
aux Français quelque chose dont ils ne
veulent pas et faire en sorte qu'on est
vraiment des choses très concrètes à
leur proposer pour changer leur
quotidien puisque c'est pour cela qu'ils
nous élisent merci je rappelle que vous
défendez cette motion dès la fabrique
depuis les ivelines pour ce congrès de
Poitier du Parti socialiste qui se
tiendra début juin merci à vous la suite
du journal et depuis le 9 avril un
nouveau centre de santé municipal qui a
ouvert ses portes à trappe une structure
financée en grande partie par la
municipalité et les patients affluent
déjà yoline Torz et Mélanie
poet des locaux flamb en neuf une
surface de 400 m car attrape le nouveau
centre de santé municipal a ouvert ses
portes il y a près d'un mois la règle
d'or ici les consultations sont
conventionné secteur 1 et le tir payant
est appliqué quel que soit le niveau de
revenu le niveau de vie de tous les
habitants qu'il puissent avoir qu'il soi
menti ou non qu'il puissent avoir des
soins qui soient d'aussi bonne qualité
que si vous alliez dans un cabinet en
libéral ou ou à l'hôpital privé de
l'Ouest parisien et cetera médecin
généraliste gynécologue orthophoniste ou
encore allergologue 11 professionnels de
santé accueille les patients tous sont
en temps partiel et travaillaient déjà à
l'ancien centre de santé sé Yve Lafarge
un centre d'attente de plus de 40 ans
devenu très obsolète et aujourd'hui
définitivement fermé on a retrouvé
d'abord un peu plus d'espace hein
puisque effectivement on est dans des
locaux neufs là-bas ifarge c'était deux
appartements là on a de la lumière qui
Arve
partout on a des locaux qui sont quand
même plus plus aérés et cetera
maintenant les les personnes qui sont
sur chaise roulant ils peuvent rentrer
aussi voilà on est au normes donc c'est
vrai que c'est pour nous quelqu chose
d'important 2 million et demi d'euros
c'est le coût global de cette nouvelle
structure l'état la communauté
d'agglomération ou encore la région
participer au financement et la ville de
trappe est majoritaire à plus de 50 %.
les patients sont au rendez-vous les
délais d'attente s'allongent déjà des
recrutement pourrait être envisagé à
court terme culture à Versailles un
nouveau festival bouillon club vient de
vivre sa première édition des
association présente des concerts
également sous l'égide d'un groupe
d'étudiants mais la fête a été un peu
gâchée par la pluie Florine parfait et
William
H peinture danse ou culture générale il
y en avait pour tous les goûts samedi
une dizaine d'associations versaillaises
était présentes à venue de Paris au
festival bouillon club nous sommes venus
à l'invitation de l'association des
jeunes étudiants versaillais qui
organise cet événement c'est bouillon
culture c'est-à-dire que c'est un
mélange des associations artistiques et
les associations des étudiants de
Versailles voulez faire connaître notre
association et connaître les autres on a
trouvé ça sympathique la météo n'était
pas au rendez-vous mais je crois que ça
a bien marché quand même on était
content de de tout ce qui s'est passé
c'est c'est important pour vous
justement de de faire valoir la culture
à versaill ah tout à fait bien sûr
surtout la culture accessible pour tout
le monde plus de 300 curieux sont venus
braver la pluie et voir les
démonstrations et initiativ du festival
il y a différentes activités que mes
enfants voulaient voir moi je suis une
passionnée de jazz et il y avait de la
peinture il y avait du dessin donc il y
avait énormément de de d'activités
différentes pour l'association étudiante
pulsard dont la mission est de
promouvoir la culture locale le Paris
est réussi c'est un domaine qui est bah
qu'on met de côté qui est pas la
priorité quand c'est un problème de
crise donc ça c'est clair euh mais je
pense que au contraire dans un temps de
crise peut-être que les gens ont envie
de sortir on envie de se divertir on
envie de de de découvrir des choses
d'apprendre des choses donc je pense
qu'il y a un engouement
après il y a un enjeu en certains
endroits comme à versaill où on a
peut-être moins l'occasion de d'avoir
des événements culturels et c'est ça qui
nous a tenu à cur à versaill il n'y a
pas que le château plus de 600
associations existent et attendent
chaque année de nouveaux
adhérents mie 7e mari les comédiens
réalisateur le vcinois Franck svin
tourne son premier long métrage dans les
ivelines jusqu'au 15 juin le weekend
dernier ces équipes baptisées de ce film
baptisé coquelé se sont installé dans la
maison de repos l'Hermitage à Chevreuse
un reportage de Michel el midero et de
William
l c'est la 21 21 sur 30
30 moteur action le comédien réalisateur
Fran swin originaire de voisin le
bretonux a décidé de poser sa caméra
pendant 3 mois dans les ivines pour
tourner son tout premier long métrage
baptisé coquelé un film auto produit
réalisé à 50 ansvine et Chevreuse la
production parle d'un thème universel
l'amour alors l'histoire c'est une
romance entre une fille qui est qui est
sourde et puis un jeune homme qui va
chercher en allant voir son père dans
une maison de retraite rencontre cette
fille et ensemble il décide de partir
dans un espèce de parcours initiatique
au fur et à mesure du film Le le le
l'émotion va un peu s'étendre jusqu'à
jusqu'à devenir quelque chose d'assez
lumineux et d'assez ouvert quoi l'équipe
du film composée de six personnes
dispose d'un budget limité pour trouver
des lieux de tournage le réalisateur a
misise en place des partenariats avec
des structures yvelinoises le weekend
dernier le long métrage a été réalisé
dans une maison de repos à Chevreuse on
a accepté de voilà de qu'il puisse
tourner gracieusement son projet on
trouvve intéressant euh l'histoire en
fait de ce film on l' trouvé très
intéressante aussi on en a parlé aux
résidents à leur famille et au
représentants des familles de de la
structure et l'idée a a intéressé et les
résidents étaient très contents et puis
le côté original de la maison pouvoir la
mettre en valeur pour nous c'était
c'était important aussi voilà puisquon
est fier on est fier de la structure
donc donc c'est vrai que pouvoir
l'ouvrir sur l'extérieur pour nous c'est
voilà c'était intéressant un bon coup de
pub pour la résidence l'Ermitage le film
pourrait être diffusé dans une vingtaine
de cinémas mon but c'est de vraiment
promouvoir le film et essayer de de le
distribuer au plus large possible
pourquoi
pas sur les grosses plateformes de
distribution comme UGC Saint-Quentin ou
pâté ou des choses comme ça
euh il y a aussi les les cinémas
indépendants qui sont euh qui sont très
ouverts à ce genre de projet le tournage
devrait se terminer le 15 juin prochain
le film passera ensuite au montage avant
une diffusion dans les salles obscures
fin
2015 et puis c'est aujourd'hui la
Journée mondiale du rire une journée
lancée en 1998 pour retrouver bien
évidemment le moral nous sommes allés à
votre rencontre pour écouter vos
histoires drôles c'est notre séquence
question du jour
auparavant ça s'appelaitp vous saveiez
ce que ça voulait dire non à ne pas
employer et puis maintenant ça s'appelle
pô emploi P emploi je veux bien mais il
emploi pas chez
Paul un mec qui vient d'Afrique alors il
a beaucoup bourlinguer là-bas puis il a
beaucoup abuser de son corps quoi et
alors son service TR pièces il est dans
un très sale état alors il va avir un
tou dit voilà VO ce que j'ai docteur
est-ce que vous pouvez faire quelque
chose docteur il regarde
il dit non je peux plus rien c'est trop
tard vous connaissez la blague du papier
non elle déchire c'est nul je l'avais
dit alors il va voir le médecin chinois
le médecin chinois il regarde
ça dit oui je sais pas ah tenz prenez
une chaise montez dessus vous savez
pourquoi de GA il servait pas de ce Doig
là que c'est le
mien il monte sur la chaise puis le
médecin chinois il dit sautez alors il
saute pas et le médecin chinois dit ah B
vous voyez c'est tombé tout
seul du rire aujourd'hui c'est la fin de
ce journal en tout cas de ce mardi 5 mai
je vous retrouve dans quelques minutes
pour un nouveau numéro du 78 politique
invité ce mois-ci Michel logier le
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 5 an en Yveline pour
aborder le nouveau budget voté pour 2015
et puis Bruno milen le président du
MoDem 78 pour la création d'un nouveau
groupe de réflexion initi 78 le journal
revient demain 18h pour le
[Musique]
direct